people are suffering people are dying
entire ecosystems are collapsing we are
in the beginning of a mass extinction
and all you can talk about is the money
and fairytales of eternal economic
growth how dare you it was an
impassioned speech but one of those who
most needed to hear it wasn't in the
audience President Donald Trump was it
do to attend the UN summit and all
countries should get together and do
that and they should do it for
themselves
Trump made a surprise appearance but
only stayed to listen to Indian Prime
Minister Narendra Modi and German
Chancellor Angela Merkel Germany makes
up 1 percent of the world's population
and 2 percent of global emissions if
everyone on the planet were to act as we
do emissions would double and everyone
is more than aware of what this means
therefore we want by 2030 to reduce our
co2 emissions by 55 percent compared
with levels in 1990 and in 2050 we want
to be climate neutral fundamentally MA
Germany's Chancellor has been buffing
her green credentials sharing a picture
of her meeting tun Berg on Instagram but
the climate activists and other young
campaigners have named Germany and 4
other countries in a landmark complaint
to the UN that says in action on climate
change amounts to a violation of
children's human rights tun Berg and her
allies can only leave the summit hoping
that the world's leaders have got the
message
[Music]
well DWS Alexander phenomen was at the
summit and spoke with Jennifer Morgan
she's the executive director of
Greenpeace International for her take on
the promises the UN climate summit has
ended with more than 60 countries
promising to do more to combat climate
change do you think that this is an
encouraging signal
I think it's encouraging when any
country says we're gonna do more but we
need every country to do more we need
and then more needs to be well defined
we need to have emissions by 2030 and
that's the details really matter here
there's so much more to do many leaders
say that they would do more but they
have to think about job security and
economic growth do you think that they
have a point I think they're missing the
point so two things one is the cost of
the climate change impacts on economies
I think is not very well calculated into
the debate how much agricultural loss
there will be the I mean the air
pollution law costs as well that's one
piece and the other is that actually the
countries that are going to innovate and
move to a zero carbon economy are the
ones that are gonna have the markets for
the future so those that are holding
back on cars for example like Germany
they're gonna miss out on the markets
for the renewable electric vehicles
Angela Merkel was one of the speakers
who addressed the summit today pledging
to contribute more money to combat
climate change in Germany was always
seen as a sort of champion when we talk
about climate change action is this
still the case unfortunately not anymore
people here especially the most
vulnerable countries they understand
that Germany is missing its target that
the climate package that was put on the
table will not get Germany to meet that
target let alone do more they need to
double down they need to come back with
a much stronger plan the Chancellor does
by the December climate cop in order to
have that credibility back thank you so
much